PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
BRANDY STRUGGLED TO KEEP
HER ATTITUDE IN CHECK.
BUT I THOUGHT YOU MIGHT
COME DOWN THE END OF THE RUNWAY
AND ACTUALLY SMACK ME
IN THE FACE.
REBECCA WENT FROM
THE JUDGING ROOM
TO THE EMERGENCY ROOM.
OH, MY GOD!
BUT SHE RECOVERED QUICKLY
AND WAS ABLE TO RETURN.
IN THE END,
SARAH'S LACK OF CONFIDENCE...
SARAH, IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE,
WE DON'T BELIEVE.
...SENT HER HOME.
12 GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪&♪&♪&
LAST NIGHT
AT THE ELIMINATION,
MY STOMACH STARTED
TO FEEL REALLY NAUSEOUS
FOR, LIKE, A SECOND OR TWO,
AND THEN MY VISION
WAS JUST TUNNELING IN.
IT WAS BLACK AND WHITE
AND FUZZY.
OH, MY GOD!
BEFORE I KNEW IT,
I WOKE UP ON THE FLOOR.
I HAVE HAD PROBLEMS WITH THIS
EVER SINCE I WAS 3 YEARS OLD.
WHAT HAPPENS IS THE VAGUS NERVE
IN YOUR BODY JUST KIND OF
GO HAYWIRE.
IT'S NOT
A LIFE-AND-DEATH CONDITION.
IT'S JUST VERY SCARY THING,
AND IT'S GONNA BE OKAY.
DO YOU STILL FEEL
A LITTLE BIT SLUGGISH?
LIKE, TOUCHING MY SHOULDER
IS, LIKE, IT HURTS.
THIS IS NOT GONNA AFFECT
MY MODELING CAREER,
MY MODELING LIFE.
IT'S JUST A DAY IN MY LIFE
THAT WAS JUST A PAIN
IN THE BUTT,
AND IT'S OVER WITH,
AND NOW WE CAN GET BACK
ON TRACK.
I ALMOST GOT ELIMINATED...
IT LOOKS LIKE A PORNO COVER
TO ME.
BECAUSE I WAS STILL
SHOWING THIS SEX KITTEN
OR WHATEVER VIBE,
AND SO I WANT TO REALLY SHOW
THAT I CAN HAVE
A DIFFERENT LOOK.
I DON'T WANT TO BE KNOWN
THAT I LOOK LIKE SOMEONE
WHO DOES PORN.
HOW LONG ARE YOU GONNA BE?
FIVE MINUTES, IF THAT.
LIKE, 'CAUSE IF YOU WANT
TO GO AFTER HER,
- THEN I'LL GO AFTER YOU.
- ARE YOU SURE?
TODAY WE WERE WAITING
TO USE THE PHONE.
I WANT TO CALL, YOU KNOW,
MY BOYFRIEND, ANDY.
I'M GONNA GO LAST
BECAUSE I'M THREE HOURS BEHIND.
WE DECIDED WE WOULD GO
FROM EAST COAST TO WEST COAST.
YOU KNOW, IT'S THREE HOURS LATER
AND THEN TWO HOURS LATER.
I CALLED WAY IN THE KITCHEN.
I SAID, AFTER NOELLE
I WAS GONNA USE THE PHONE,
AND THEN Y'ALL GOT TOGETHER
AND WAS LIKE...
YOU WEREN'T OUT HERE,
SWEETIE, AND WE'VE ALL
BEEN WAITING IN LINE.
FIRST COME, FIRST SERVE.
OKAY, WELL, THERE YOU GO.
Y'ALL NEED TO SAY IT
TO EVERYBODY.
BRANDY STARTS FREAKING OUT,
AND WE'RE, LIKE, "CALM DOWN."
I MEAN, IF Y'ALL WANT
TO GET RUDE ABOUT IT,
THEN WE CAN GET RUDE,
BUT ALL I'M SAYING, IT'S...
BRANDY--LIKE,
SHE HAS AN ATTITUDE PROBLEM,
BUT TIFFANY
WILL LET HER KNOW, LIKE,
"BRANDY, YOU NEED TO STOP."
ALL I'M SAYING IS THAT--
FINE, YOU--
SHE GONNA USE THE PHONE.
I THINK BRANDY REALLY
LOOKS UP TO ME NOW.
I TELL HER, "YOU REMIND ME
OF THE OLD TIFFANY,
BUT DON'T BECOME THAT GIRL.
DON'T BE THAT TIFFANY,
BECAUSE SHE WAS CRAZY."
OH!
(screams)
THAT STANK HOE
POURED A BEER ON MY WEAVE!
I'M NOT ABOUT
TO FIGHT NO MORE.
MY GRANDMA TOLD ME,
SHE WAS LIKE,
"WHAT YOU GONNA TELL PEOPLE?
WHAT ARE WE GONNA WRITE
ON YOUR TOMBSTONE?"
YOU KNOW,
"SHE'S DEAD, BUT SHE WHUPPED
EVERYBODY'S ASS,
YOU KNOW?"
I HAD TO BE HARD.
THAT'S WHO I WAS.
BUT I'M GLAD NOT
TO HAVE TO BE THAT PERSON NOW,
AND IT'S LIKE BRANDY'S TRYING
TO BE THAT OLD GIRL.
THAT'S NOT THE RIGHT WAY
TO LIVE.
SHOOT.
TYRA MAIL!
"YOU BETTER BE ON POINT,
BECAUSE I HAVE NO TIME
FOR NONSENSE.
BE READY AT 12:00 P.M."
MAYBE IT'S INTERVIEWS
AND STUFF.
WE GET TYRA MAIL THAT SAYS
SOMETHING ABOUT BEING ON POINT.
WE WALK IN
AND THERE IS STANDING,
LIKE, THIS SHORT LITTLE MAN
WITH A BEARD AND A CANE.
LIKE, IT WAS
THE MOST EXCITING THING EVER.
I'M STEFAN WENTA,
THIS IS THE DANCERS' STUDIO.
I'M GOING TO INTRODUCE YOU
INTO YOUR FIRST BALLET CLASS.
I'M READY TO HOP INTO
THAT LITTLE LEOTARD AND TIGHTS.
YOU ARE GOING TO
USE YOUR BODY
AS AN INSTRUMENT
OF EXPRESSION, EH?
THE GOOD, VERY GOOD MODELS
MUST BE FORM CONSCIOUS.
THAT MEANS SHE KNOWS
AT ANY GIVEN MOMENT
HOW SHE LOOKS, OKAY?
SO LET'S DO NOW
THE DEMI-PLIE.
ONE AND TWO.
ARM FRONT...
AND SIDE.
♪&♪&♪&
UP, UP.
LOWER, YES.
STRAIGHT BODY.
THAT'S GOOD.
SHOULDER.
THE GUY WAS CRAZY,
WHACKING US A WITH A CANE.
HE'S LIKE, "SHOULDERS DOWN!"
YOU'RE A LITTLE STIFF
AND TENSE, BUT THAT'S NORMAL.
THAT'S NORMAL.
OKAY, WE GO.
SHOULDER.
I'M LIKE, OH, PLEASE,
LITTLE MAN, SIR,
STEFAN, DON'T
COME BEAT ME UP.
I WAS SO SCARED.
YOU'RE LUCKY
THAT I AM SUCH A GENTLEMAN.
YOU HAVE DONE BALLET
A LITTLE BIT?
- YEAH.
- YOU SEE, I SEE IT RIGHT HERE.
THAT'S A GOOD ARM.
STEFAN DID RECOGNIZE
THAT I HAD BALLET TRAINING.
I WOULD HOPE SO.
I'VE BEEN DANCING
FOR A FEW YEARS, SO...
FRONT, SHARP.
WHAT? YOU CAN DO IT.
IT WILL BE GOOD FOR YOU,
REALLY, OKAY?
BECAUSE THIS DISCIPLINE
WILL AFFECT MANY OTHER THINGS
MAYBE EVEN IN YOUR LIFE.
I'M NOT USED TO
CONTROLLING MY BODY.
MY BODY CONTROLS ME,
SO THIS IS REALLY HARD FOR ME.
- OKAY, THANK YOU, GIRLS.
- THANK YOU.
I WISH YOU WELL.
WELCOME TO
THE PACIFIC DINING CAR.
THANK YOU.
WE ARE GOING TO DINNER
JUST LET LOOSE AND, LIKE,
JUST HAVE A NIGHT
FOR US GIRLS.
WHAT SHALL WE ORDER,
LADIES?
WHAT SHALL WE ORDER?
I'VE NEVER BEEN
TO A NICE PLACE LIKE THIS.
I HAVE BEEN DOING THINGS
I NEVER REALLY WOULD HAVE
THOUGHT I COULD DO,
SO IT'S LIKE,
IT'S A REALLY BIG CHANGE
FOR ME.
IT'S REALLY HARD.
I DON'T GET DRUNK ANYMORE.
NO MORE.
I ACT LIKE A FOOL
WHEN I GET DRUNK,
ONE GLASS OF WINE,
SOFT DRINK.
I'D LIKE A GLASS
OF WHITE WINE, PLEASE?
- CHARDONNAY?
- SAME HERE.
VERY WELL, MA'AM.
DANG, TIFFANY.
IF YOU GET CUT BEFORE ME
OR IF I GET CUT BEFORE YOU,
I WANT YOU TO GO HOME KNOWING
THAT YOU, YOU AND YOU
AND EVEN YOU HAVE TOUCHED ME
AND MADE ME THINK DIFFERENT
ABOUT A LOT OF THINGS,
AND I LOVE YOU.
I DO.
I MEAN, SIX MONTHS AGO,
I WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN HERE.
I'VE BEEN CHANGING SO MUCH.
TIFFANY HAD, I THINK,
FOUR GLASSES, AND, I MEAN,
SHE WAS DOING ALL RIGHT,
BUT THEN, I WAS LIKE,
"GOD, IT'S COMIN'.
HERE WE GO."
I DO WHAT I DO
THE WAY I DO IT.
OKAY, GO AHEAD, LLUVY.
TIFFANY'S VERY TALKATIVE.
YOU KNOW IF TIFFANY'S AROUND
AND YOU KNOW IF SHE'S
NOT AROUND,
BUT I REALIZED THAT
I DON'T HEAR TIFFANY,
AND THEN ALL OF THE SUDDEN...
TIFFANY'S JUST, LIKE,
SLUNG OVER HER CHAIR
JUST THROWING UP
AND THE WHOLE ROOM
JUST STARTED STINKING
AND I WAS LIKE... (gasps)
FEELING BETTER?
SHE WAS ASKING
FOR SOME JUICE.
IS THERE ANYTHING
I CAN GET YOU, SWEETHEART?
TIFFANY CAN BE A PROFESSIONAL
AND MAKE IT APPEAR THAT
HER PERSONAL PROBLEMS
ARE ALL OUT THE WINDOW,
BUT SOMETIMES SHE CAN BE
OLD TIFFANY.
I'M MISERABLE.
I AM MISERABLE.
THIS IS NOT ME.
THIS--THIS IS NOT--
THIS IS NOT TIFFANY.
THAT'S NOT WHO I AM.
WE WENT TO DINNER,
AND TIFFANY HAD, I THINK,
FOUR GLASSES OF WINE,
AND IF SHE HAD NOT
DRUNK THAT MUCH ALCOHOL,
THE FOOD WOULD HAVE STAYED DOWN,
BUT I JUST TRIED
TO BE A GOOD FRIEND
AND, YOU KNOW,
HELP HER OUT.
IT'S HURTIN' ME
JUST TO KNOW THAT
I'M NOT HOME WITH MY CHILD,
MY BABY'S FATHER, MY GRANDMA.
I MEAN, THIS IS, LIKE,
THE FIRST TIME I'VE EVER
BEEN AWAY FROM MY FAMILY
AND EVERYTHING,
AND, I MEAN, I'M FEELIN'--
I'M MISSIN' 'EM, BUT, I MEAN,
I HAVE NO IDEA, LIKE,
WHAT YOU'RE FEELIN',
BECAUSE, I MEAN,
YOU HAVE A CHILD AND EVERYTHING.
HONESTLY, BEIN' HERE
IS HARDER THAN BEIN' A MOM
BECAUSE THIS IS
A WHOLE NEW WORLD FOR ME.
IT TOOK TIME FOR ME
TO GROW INTO HAVIN' A CHILD
AND BEIN' A PARENT,
I JUST WAS THROWN INTO THIS.
MAYBE I'M JUST BEIN'
A BIG BABY TODAY.
I WISH I COULD
HELP YOU, TIFFANY. HERE.
THIS MORNING...
IT WAS A TOTAL SURPRISE.
WE SHOW UP
AT THIS SMALL RESTAURANT,
AND WE WALK IN,
AND I SEE THIS GORGEOUS WOMAN
STANDING THERE.
WELCOME.
HI.
I'M BEVERLY JOHNSON,
AND WE'RE GONNA
HAVE SOME FUN TODAY.
I WAS JUST LIKE,
"OH, MY GOD."
ALL I CAN SAY IS "WOW."
SHE IS THE FIRST
BLACK SUPERMODEL.
I BECAME
THE FIRST AFRICAN-AMERICAN
TO GRACE THE COVER OF "VOGUE"
IN AUGUST OF 1974,
AND IT MADE HISTORY.
IT FEELS SO EMPOWERING
TO BE SITTING NEXT TO
THIS WOMAN WHO'S ACCOMPLISHED
SO MUCH IN HER LIFE.
I WAS YOUR AGE,
AND I HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
TO GET AN APPOINTMENT
WITH "GLAMOUR" MAGAZINE,
AND THEY SAID,
"YOU'RE JUST WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR,"
AND I WENT ON A 10-DAY SHOOT
WITH THIS PHOTOGRAPHER.
UGH.
"AH, YOU LOOK TERRIBLE.
I TOLD YOU NO MAKEUP.
GO BACK."
I WAS, LIKE, CRYING.
I WAS, LIKE, IN TEARS.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN EASY
FOR ME TO SIT UP HERE AND SAY,
"OKAY, I WOULD'VE ABSORBED
WHAT THEY SAID
AND TOOK IT LIKE THIS AND--"
I WOULD HAVE BROKE DOWN
LIKE A BABY.
MS. BEVERLY JOHNSON
IS REALLY AN INSPIRATION TO ME,
AND I THINK SHE LOOKS LIKE ME
A LITTLE BIT, BUT...
WHAT KIND OF ATTITUDE
SHOULD YOU HAVE, BECAUSE,
ME--I DON'T REALLY HAVE,
LIKE, A BAD ATTITUDE,
BUT SOMETIMES I CAN
GET TO THAT POINT WHERE I JUST
WANT TO GO OFF ON SOMEBODY.
AS FAR AS HAVING A TEMPER,
YOU HAVE THESE, YOU KNOW,
PHOTOGRAPHERS AND EDITORS
AND STYLISTS THAT ARE,
YOU KNOW, VERY TEMPERAMENTAL,
SO ONE HAS TO NOT TAKE
EVERYTHING REALLY PERSONAL.
SHE JUST, LIKE,
ANSWERED ALL OUR QUESTIONS.
SHE WAS AMAZING.
- BYE.
AH.
YEAH, THIS DOESN'T WORK.
TYRA MAIL.
"YOU ARE IN CONTROL
OF YOUR OWN DESTINY.
BE READY AT 1:00."
- OKAY.
- WHY?
I DON'T KNOW.
WE'RE ALL LIKE, "OOH, YOU KNOW,
I WONDER WHAT IT IS."
WE TRY TO FIGURE OUT
EVERY SINGLE TYRA MAIL
AND WE NEVER GET IT RIGHT.
I WALK UP THE HILL
AND SEE A TENNIS COURT
AND THIS PHOTOGRAPHER.
I DON'T SEE, LIKE,
JAY ANYWHERE.
WHAT THE GIRLS DON'T KNOW
IS THAT THIS IS A CHALLENGE,
AND I'LL BE SECRETLY
WATCHING THEM TO SEE
WHO CAN HANDLE
EXTREME PRESSURE.
I WAS INSTRUCTED TO
PRETTY MUCH TEAR THEM TO SHREDS.
THIS IS
A VERY REALISTIC SITUATION.
YOU HAVE, LIKE,
A PHOTOGRAPHER WHO'S A JERK.
EVEN THE CLIENT
MAY HATE YOU.
THE ONLY THING
YOU HAVE CONTROL OVER
IS HOW WELL YOU DO.
PROVE TO THEM
THAT YOU'RE THE STAR.
WE'RE GONNA BE SHOOTING
FOR A LOCAL SPORTS MAGAZINE
HERE IN LOS ANGELES.
YOU GUYS ARE GONNA BE
PLAYING TENNIS.
TIME IS GONNA BE
EXTREMELY LIMITED,
SO I EXPECT YOU GUYS TO GET
YOUR STUFF ON THE MARK, OKAY?
I WAS THE VERY FIRST
ONE TO GO,
AND THEY WERE LIKE,
"HAIR, MAKEUP.
YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES."
I WAS LIKE, "FIVE MINUTES?
DO YOU SEE MY HAIR?"
SO BY THE TIME I EVEN
MADE IT OUT TO THE COURT,
I WAS ALREADY
A LITTLE FRUSTRATED.
SO THE BALLS ARE GONNA BE
COMING RIGHT AT YOU.
SO I KNOW YOU GUYS
TOOK BALLET YESTERDAY, RIGHT?
YEAH.
OKAY, SO I NEED YOU
TO KIND OF INCORPORATE
THOSE MOVEMENTS.
OKAY, SWEETS,
SO THIS IS GONNA BE
YOUR MARK RIGHT HERE, OKAY?
BUT YOU'RE GONNA BE
COMING FROM OVER HERE.
I HAVE A QUESTION, THOUGH.
IS THIS WHERE MY FOOT'S GOING
OR IS THIS WHERE I--
LIKE, THE END OF MY BODY
NEEDS TO BE?
BECAUSE I JUST WANT
TO GET THIS STRAIGHT.
COME AGAIN.
THIS IS WHERE
MY BODY IS GONNA BE,
LIKE, A LINE, RIGHT?
THIS IS WHERE YOU'RE GONNA--
YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
PREFERABLY I'D LIKE YOU
TO HIT THE BALL,
BUT IF YOU DON'T,
I NEED YOU TO BE MORE GRACEFUL.
I NEED THAT KIND OF A--
I MEAN, IF I CAN DO IT,
YOU CAN DO IT, OKAY?
I LOOK GOOD DOING IT, TOO.
THIS PHOTOGRAPHER
WAS JUST INSANE.
DO WE NEED
SOME COFFEE FOR YOU?
'CAUSE YOU LOOK LIKE
YOU'RE STILL SLEEPIN'.
- NO.
- YOU SURE?
'CAUSE WE CAN GET
SOME COFFEE HERE.
I'M LOOKING AT A FRIGHTENED GIRL
WHO IS SCARED
OF THIS PHOTO SHOOT.
I REALLY JUST WANTED
TO GET OFF THAT COURT.
I REALLY DID.
NEXT.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHY YOU WOULD BE SO RUDE
AND SO MEAN TO ANYONE.
AND THE BALL'S COMING.
PRETEND.
OKAY, YOU'RE GONNA HIT IT
OR WHAT?
- OKAY.
- "OKAY?"
I MEAN, "OKAY" IS FINE.
I MEAN, I LIKE TO HEAR "OKAY,"
BUT I NEED YOU TO DO IT.
- OKAY.
- NOT OKAY.
YOU'RE NOT DOING IT.
WRONG FOOT--
YOU STARTED WITH THE WRONG FOOT.
START WITH THE OTHER FOOT.
UGH...
AAH!
IT FEELS LIKE
MY CONFIDENCE HAS BEEN
THROWN OUT OF A MOVING CAR
AND RUN OVER A COUPLE TIMES.
IT'S GRACE AND FORWARD,
GRACE AND FORWARD.
I WANTED TO SLAP THAT BOY
UPSIDE HIS HALF BALDING HEAD
AAH!
I NEED YOU TO LOOK LIKE
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'RE DOING
AND LOOKING GRACEFUL
AT THE SAME TIME.
EXTEND THAT LEG!
POINT YOUR FOOT!
POINT IT. POINT IT. AAH!
THE LONGER
THE SHOOT LASTED,
THE MORE NEUROTIC
THIS MAN SEEMED TO BE...
AND I HAD TO LAUGH
AT THIS GUY.
NAIMA DID A GOOD JOB.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT WAS
RUNNING THROUGH HER MIND,
BUT SHE SEEMED
ON THE SURFACE THAT,
"OKAY, I CAN HANDLE THIS."
NO LIFE. NO PERSONALITY.
NO GRACEFULNESS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT
YOU GUYS WERE DOING
WHEN THEY WERE
TALKING ABOUT GRACE TO YOU
OR POSTURE, ANYTHING.
NONE OF YOU HAVE IT.
I DID SEE MICHELLE
START TO CRY
AS SHE WALKED
OFF THE COURT.
SOME OF THEM
ARE LIKE THAT.
YOU HAVE TO DEAL WITH IT.
I MEAN,
NOT EVERYONE IS GONNA BE
SWEET AS PIE
AND NICE TO US.
THEY'RE GONNA FLAT-OUT
TELL US.
NO, HE WAS BEING MEAN.
SIMPLE. IT'S SIMPLE, OKAY?
DON'T ACT.
CELEBRATE, FOR REAL--
I DON'T HAVE TIME! COME ON!
SERIOUSLY, PUT YOURSELF
TOGETHER. FOCUS!
UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES, KEENYAH
HELD HER COMPOSURE PRETTY WELL.
RELAX, LOOSEN YOUR LIPS
UP A LITTLE BIT.
YOU'RE HAVING A GOOD TIME.
IT'S NOT THE END OF THE WORLD
RIGHT NOW.
NOTE TO SELF,
DO NOT PRINT THIS ROLL, PLEASE.
OOH, SHE'S COMING OUT.
SHE'S COMIN' OUT.
WE'RE UP HERE
AND WE KNOW TIFFANY'S COMIN' UP.
PLEASE, TIFFANY,
HIT HIM IN THE HEAD.
HIT ALEX IN THE HEAD
WITH THIS RACKET.
I'M ABOUT TO
GET REALLY PISSED.
I'M THINKING IN MY HEAD,
"YEAH, I'M GONNA GO OUT HERE.
I'M GONNA PLAY TENNIS.
I'M GONNA DO THE POSE GREAT.
- OUCH!
- YOU WANT ME TO DO THIS?
I MEAN, I CAN DO IT MYSELF.
THAT'S NOT WHY I'M HERE.
MAN, THIS FOOL
KEEPS BOTHERING ME.
DO ME A FAVOR,
BOUNCE A LITTLE BIT.
WE'RE GONNA DANCE IT OUT.
OMAR, YOU'RE GONNA SHOOT THIS.
SHOOT THIS FOR ME.
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU A LITTLE...
♪& TIKA TIKA TIKA TIKA ♪&
♪& DA DA DA DA
DA DA DA DA DA ♪&
♪& DA KA DA KA
DA KA DA KA ♪&♪&
DANCE, DANCE, DANCE!
HE HAD ME DOIN' SOME
DUMBASS JUMPIN' MOVE
THAT AIN'T HAVE NOTHIN'
TO DO WITH TENNIS.
RIGHT NOW YOU'RE GIVING ME
A LOT OF, JUST,
STRAIGHT-OUT ATTITUDE
WITHOUT ANYTHING HAPPENING.
TELL ME WHAT YOU NEED
FROM ME.
I DON'T NEED
ANYTHING FROM YOU.
I'M NOT--
I'M NOT DIGGING HER ATTITUDE.
I REALLY AM NOT.
WHEN YOU'RE READY TO WORK,
YOU COME TO ME, OKAY?
'CAUSE, ATTITUDE--
YOU CAN LEAVE IT AT HOME,
FOR GRANDMA OR FOR WHOEVER,
NOT FOR ME!
I'LL TAKE THAT
TO YOUR GRANDMA OR WHOEVER.
OKAY, GO.
OH, HE HAD ME OUT THERE
BOUNCING LIKE THIS.
I SAW YOU. I SAW YOU.
HE'S TALKING ABOUT,
"TIKA TIKA TIKA TIKA TIKA."
(laughs)
HONESTLY, I WANT TO DO THE WHOLE
THING OVER AND JUST LAUGH
AT EVERYTHING HE SAID.
THAT WAS NOT FUN,
HE PISSED ME OFF.
- LET'S GO.
- ALL RIGHT.
UM, WOULD YOU--
ARE YOU GONNA CLARIFY, LIKE,
IF I'M DOING IT WRONG?
- OR IS IT JUST ME--
- OH, I'LL CLARIFY.
- OKAY.
- I'LL DEFINITELY CLARIFY.
- RELAX. RELAX.
OOH.
"OOH?"
BABE, NOT JUMPING.
I DON'T NEED YOU TO JUMP.
I NEED YOU TO STAY IN ONE SPOT
AND JUST KIND OF LIFT A LEG UP.
AY, MY GOD, MY GOD,
MY GOD, MY GOD, MY GOD, MY GOD.
- LET'S GO.
- POOR BRANDY.
OH, BRANDY'S GONNA
GO OFF ON HIM.
- ALL RIGHT, LET'S TRY IT.
- HOW DO I DO MY FACE?
HOW DO YOU DO YOUR FACE?
WHAT KIND OF A QUESTION IS THAT,
I DON'T KNOW IF--
I MEAN, THEY ALWAYS SAY WE NEED
- TO LOOK FIERCE, SO I DON'T--
- FIERCE? WHAT IS FIERCE?
IS THAT FIERCE?
I WANT YOU TO BE YOU.
I WANT YOU
TO BE COMFORTABLE.
I WANT YOU TO LOOK LIKE
YOU'RE HAVING A GOOD TIME
PLAYING THE GAME.
OOH, SHOOT.
WELL, I DIDN'T HIT THAT.
I CAN'T HIT IT.
HEY, LOOK,
I DON'T WANNA HEAR
THAT YOU CAN'T HIT IT,
'CAUSE RIGHT NOW I'M GETTING,
"I CAN'T HIT IT,
I CAN'T HIT IT. I CAN'T HIT IT."
THAT'S NOT THE SHOT
I'M LOOKING FOR.
DON'T LOOK MEAN.
I CAN'T HIDE MY EMOTIONS,
NOT WITH MY FACE.
IT SHOWS.
I CAN'T HIDE IT.
SEE, LOOK AT MY FACE,
I'M HAPPY.
I'M COMING TO GET THE BALL,
OKAY? NOT--
I'M COMING AT YOU,
I'M GONNA KILL YOU.
BRANDY NEEDS TO KEEP
THE TOUGHNESS ON THE INSIDE
BUT LOOK LIKE A SOFT,
SUPPLE MODEL ON THE OUTSIDE.
GOD KNOWS, I'M TRYING
TO WORK ON MY ATTITUDE,
BUT HE ALMOST GOT
A SHOE UPSIDE THE HEAD.
WHEN WE WERE IN THE HOUSE,
THERE WAS A LOT OF TENSION
FROM JUST HAVING TO DEAL
WITH THIS JERK.
IF THIS PICTURE IS UGLY,
YOU KNOW THE FIRST THING
THEY'RE GONNA BE LIKE,
"YOU LOOK LIKE YOU'RE MAD."
THEY ALREADY ASSOCIATE ME
WITH ANGER AND I DON'T--
I'M NOT EVEN--I DON'T EVEN
BE ANGRY HALF THE TIME.
THE JUDGES ARE GONNA BE LIKE,
"YOUR HAIR LOOKS LIKE CRAP.
WHAT IS YOUR EYE DOING?
WHY IS IT TWITCHING?
TATIANA--
SHE MAKES LITTLE SMART REMARKS,
AND SHE JUST
GOT ON MY NERVES.
- BRANDY, RELAX, PLEASE.
- SHUT UP.
GIRL, DON'T SAY--DON'T SAY--
DON'T TELL ME TO SHUT UP.
I WASN'T TALKING TO YOU.
YOU WERE JUST ASKING NAIMA
IF YOU CAN SLAP--
SHE STARTS YELLING AT ME,
AND I'M JUST LIKE, "WHOA..."
- OKAY--
- I WAS MAKING A JOKE
TO MAKE MYSELF LAUGH.
DON'T SAY NOTHIN' TO ME.
IF I DON'T SHUT UP TALKIN',
YOU DON'T SAY NOTHIN' TO ME
BECAUSE I AIN'T SAID
NOTHIN' ELSE TO YOU,
AND YOU DON'T KNOW ME LIKE THAT
TO BE SITTIN' UP HERE
GIVIN' ME
ATTITUDE OVER NOTHIN'.
BRANDY SEEMS
TO BE CONFRONTATIONAL
SO SHE'LL FIND ANY EXCUSE
TO JUST START
TAKING IT OUT ON SOMEONE.
IF WE DIDN'T GET KICKED OUT
FOR HITTIN' SOMEBODY,
YOUR ASS WOULD BE
TORE UP RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE I AIN'T SAID...
TO YOU.
- I'M SURE, BRANDY, I'M SURE.
- YEAH, YOU BETTER BE SURE.
- YEAH, I'M SURE.
- YOU BETTER BE REAL SURE.
AND IF WE COULD HIT PEOPLE,
YOUR ASS WOULD BE
TORE UP RIGHT NOW,
BUT BECAUSE WE CAN'T,
THEN I'M GONNA SIT UP
IN THIS CHAIR AND RESPECT YOU.
TATIANA AND BRANDY
WERE EXCHANGING WORDS.
I'M THINKING GIRLS
ARE GONNA START FIGHTING.
NO, DON'T SAY NOTHIN' TO ME.
BRANDY, THIS IS
SOMEBODY ELSE'S HOUSE,
AND THEY'RE HERE.
GIRL, I DON'T EVEN CARE
RIGHT NOW.
DON'T--SHE DON'T NEED TO SAY
NOTHIN' ELSE TO ME.
- THAT DON'T MAKE NO SENSE.
- BABY, YOU SHOULD CARE.
BRANDY--
SHE'S GOT SUCH A BAD ATTITUDE.
SHE DOESN'T BELONG HERE.
EVERYONE'S FINISHED,
SO WE GO DOWNSTAIRS.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
HEY. HI.
JAY WALKS OUT
AND WE WERE LIKE,
OHH, WE'RE IN TROUBLE."
TODAY'S CHALLENGE WAS TO SEE
HOW WELL YOU GUYS CAN HANDLE
A HIGH-PRESSURE SITUATION.
HE WAS ACTUALLY INSTRUCTED
TO BE OVER-THE-TOP AND HARSH.
THE REAL TWIST
IS I WATCHED.
AND MISS TIFFANY--
SHE HAD THAT RACKET.
- SHE WAS GONNA THROTTLE YOU.
- I FELT IT.
BUT YOU DIDN'T.
BUT I WANTED TO.
I JUST CAN'T BELIEVE
IT WAS ALL JUST A BIG JOKE.
YOU DON'T DO THIS
TO PEOPLE.
SO, ALEX,
YOU GOTTA PICK A WINNER
OF TODAY'S CHALLENGE.
UM, OKAY, THE WINNER IS
GOING TO GO TO A VERY, VERY
NICE, ELEGANT DINNER TONIGHT
WITH A VERY SPECIAL PERSON.
AND I PICK, UH, NAIMA.
AW...
- COME HERE, NAIMA.
- GOOD WORK.
THANK YOU.
YOU GET TO PICK TWO FRIENDS.
KAHLEN, TIFFANY.
WE SHOW UP TO THE RESTAURANT
AND WE'RE WAITING,
WE'RE WAITING.
WHO IS THIS PERSON
GONNA BE?
WHO'S THIS GUEST?
(gasps)
HEY, GIRL.
AND OUT OF THE DOOR
WALKS SERENA WILLIAMS.
HEY, I'M LOOKING FOR NAIMA.
OH, THAT'S ME.
(laughs)
I HAVE A RACKET FOR YOU.
WOW, THANK YOU.
SHE BROUGHT ME A TENNIS RACKET
THAT SHE SIGNED.
I'M SORRY IF I'M JUST,
LIKE, STARING AT YOU.
OH, NO, NO, NO, IT'S OKAY.
YOU ALL ARE SO PRETTY.
YOU KNOW,
AT FIRST I DIDN'T THINK THAT,
YOU KNOW, I WOULD REALLY,
LIKE, RELATE TO HER.
I HAVE A COMPANY, ANERES.
I DESIGN MY OWN CLOTHES.
IT'S MY NAME
SPELLED BACKWARDS.
WOW...
AND I ACTUALLY
AM A FASHION DESIGNER,
SO I CAN GIVE YOU GUYS
A FEW TIPS.
YOUR WALK IS HOT.
GOOD JOB.
THANK YOU.
- I LIKE THE WALK.
- PUT ME ON THE SPOT.
PLEASE DON'T LAUGH.
I DON'T LIKE BEIN' HUMILIATED,
SO I WAS NERVOUS AT FIRST.
I LIKE IT.
IT'S SEXY. THAT IS SEXY.
BUT THEN I LOOSENED UP
A LITTLE BIT.
SHE'S NOTHING
LIKE I EXPECTED.
SO I SAW THAT
YOU REALLY FOCUSED ON ME
WHICH IS GOOD.
THAT'S WHAT MISS TYRA SAID.
- OH, REALLY?
- SHE SAID I DO THE BLANK STARE.
IT FEELS GREAT TO BE HERE.
I'M LEARNING NEW THINGS
AND I'M LOVING IT A WHOLE LOT.
I'LL SEE ALL OF YOU GUYS
ON THE RUNWAY. GOOD LUCK!
- ALL RIGHT.
- GOOD LUCK.
- THANK YOU.
- BYE.
BYE.
KAHLEN,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO COME
READ THE NEW TYRA MAIL?
"LIONS ROAR,
FEEL IN BALANCE.
GET READY TO SOAR
TOMORROW AT 7:30 A.M."
I AM REALLY EXCITED
BECAUSE I HAVE BEEN WAITING
TO, YOU KNOW, GET UP IN THE AIR
AND DO SOMETHING.
- HOW ARE YOU GUYS DOIN'?
- GOOD.
HOW MANY TIMES HAVE YOU GUYS
BEEN OUT IN THE CLUB
AND A MAN IS LIKE,
"WHAT'S YOUR SIGN, GIRL?
YOU LOOK SO FINE.
WHAT'S YOUR SIGN?"
HOW MANY TIMES?
- OHH...
- A MILLION TIMES.
SO THE 12 OF YOU
ARE GOING TO BE
THE SIGNS
OF THE ZODIAC TODAY.
YAY.
WE'VE GOT A HOLLYWOOD
STUNT COORDINATOR,
AND HE IS GONNA PUT
EACH AND EVERY ONE OF YOU
IN HARNESSES,
AND WE'RE GONNA RAISE YOU UP.
SO THIS IS MIKE.
- HI.
- HI, MIKE.
AND THIS IS
TRACY, YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER.
AND ALSO, AS YOU GUYS KNOW,
THERE'S 12 OF YOU.
YOU GUYS ARE ALSO
SHOOTING A CALENDAR.
(gasps)
- ARE YOU GUYS READY?
- YEAH!
LET'S GO!
HEY.
SO YOU GUYS
ARE GONNA BE WEARING
CALVIN KLEIN,
LEJABY ROSE,
WARNER'S, JLO--LINGERIE
BY JENNIFER LOPEZ,
AND OLGA
FOR A WARNECO CALENDAR.
SO LET'S START.
THIS IS HOW YOU'RE GONNA LOOK
WHEN IT'S ALL DONE.
SO YOU'RE GONNA
PAINT ALL THIS BLOOD?
NOT ALL OF IT.
DO YOU KNOW
YOU'RE GONNA LOOK CRAZY?
IT'S THE CHALLENGE.
TIFFANY,
GUESS WHAT YOU ARE.
I'M A SHRIMP.
WHY I GOTTA BE A SHRIMP?
HOW CAN I BE SEXY
IF I'M A CRAB?
I LOOK LIKE A FISH.
SHE DOES.
I AM HEARING
THAT I'M PISCES.
I'M LIKE, "OH, GREAT,
THEY'RE GONNA PUT BIG OLD,
LIKE, BIGGER LIPS
THAN I ALREADY HAVE."
MISS NAIMA, COME ON OUT.
OH, BEAUTIFUL.
I WAS CAPRICORN,
THE GOAT.
OKAY, MIKE, TAKE TENSION.
RIGHT IN THE KNEE
RIGHT IN THE KNEE, SWEETIE.
DON'T BE DEAD
WITH THE HANDS.
DON'T JUST STAY LIKE THIS
AND JUST THINK
YOUR EXPRESSION'S
GONNA CHANGE.
BEING A BALLERINA,
I THOUGHT NAIMA WOULD HAVE
MORE GRACE AND MOVEMENT,
BUT SHE DOESN'T HAVE
THAT SAME POW
THAT SHE NORMALLY DOES.
GO ON?
HOLD THAT.
AND I WAS REALLY
SCARED AT FIRST
'CAUSE WE COULDN'T REALLY
GET MY BALANCE.
DON'T WORRY,
WE'LL JUST GIVE YOU A SECOND.
EVERYONE TAKES A MINUTE.
DON'T GET NERVOUS.
THAT'S GORGEOUS, SWEETIE.
I KIND OF, YOU KNOW,
FOUND MY CENTER.
IT GOT BETTER AFTER THAT.
GREAT, SWEETIE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
EXCELLENT.
WHY IS HE TAKING SO LONG
TO DO YOUR HAIR, BRANDY?
I SAY HE JUST
DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO.
I WAS THE FIRST ONE
DONE WITH MAKE UP,
AND I WAS LIKE,
"OH, MY GOD."
THE MAN--
HE REALLY DIDN'T WANNA ADMIT
THAT HE JUST DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT HAIRSTYLE TO DO WITH ME
BECAUSE MY HAIR IS SHORT.
YOU'RE GONNA BE
ON THE ATTACK TOWARDS ME, OKAY?
GO INTO THAT--
AND LIKE YOU'RE--
NOW, YOU'RE NOT
GONNA FALL OFF.
YOU NEED TO GET MUCH MORE
INTO THE CHARACTER.
YOU'RE A LION, LIKE...
(roars)
IN THIS SITUATION,
NOELLE DID NOT LOOK
LIKE A PROUD LION,
AND I'M A LEO,
SO I'M PISSED.
YEAH, YOU CAN BRING YOUR ARMS
FORWARD I THINK, RIGHT?
I LIKE THAT COY
LITTLE POSE.
YOU'RE JUST GONNA HAVE TO
GIVE US A VARIETY
OF FACIAL EXPRESSIONS.
- ALL RIGHT.
- DON'T FORGET YOUR FACE.
TODAY KEENYAH DEFINITELY GAVE US
A RANGE OF EXPRESSION.
HEY, BRITTANY,
WHAT ARE YOU THINKING RIGHT NOW?
NO SEX KITTEN FACE
IS WHAT I'M TRYING TO DO.
OKAY, YOU KNOW WHAT,
DON'T THINK THE NEGATIVE.
THINK THE POSITIVE.
THAT'S GREAT,
THAT'S GREAT, BABY.
I LOVE THE MOUTH OPEN
LIKE THAT, THAT'S WONDERFUL.
YOU WEREN'T HOOCHIE
IN ANYTHING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH,
I REALLY FELT IT THAT TIME.
- GOOD, YEAH, GREAT, HONEY.
- THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GONNA GET MY CLAWS ON.
GONNA GET A CLAW.
THAT'S THE WRONG HAND.
I REALLY DO THINK
THAT I'M GONNA HAVE
A GOOD PHOTO THIS TIME
EVEN THOUGH I'M A DAMN CRAB.
SO, IF ANYTHING,
THAT ONE SHOULD BE HIGHER.
TAKE THIS CLAW HIGHER
AND THIS ONE DOWN, OKAY?
YOU'RE CONCENTRATING SO HARD
ON WHAT YOU--
AND YOU'RE NOT
GONNA FALL, OKAY?
JUST BE GRACEFUL ABOUT IT.
- BEAUTIFUL, HONEY.
- YES.
THAT'S GORGEOUS
RIGHT THERE.
TIFFANY HAS GROWN
IN LEAPS AND BOUNDS
FROM OUR FIRST PHOTO SHOOT.
SHE COMMANDED THAT SET.
TODAY YOU ARE GOING TO BE
THE WOMAN OF SYMMETRY.
WHAT DO I SAY EVERY SHOOT?
SOFTEN THE EYES.
BEAUTIFUL
IN THE EYES, HONEY.
FOR WHAT I WANTED
OUT OF CHRISTINA,
SHE GAVE IT TO ME.
SHE'S GOT
A BEAUTIFUL FACE.
TATIANA,
WE'RE GONNA DO ONE SIDE
AND THEN WE'RE GONNA
SHOOT THE OTHER SIDE,
SO WHAT YOU NEED TO DO
IS YOU'RE GONNA TRY
AND REACH OUT YOUR PALM FLAT
SO THAT WE CAN DIGITALLY
PUT THE TWO PALMS TOGETHER.
DON'T TURN
WITH YOUR SHOULDERS.
KEEP YOUR SHOULDERS STRAIGHT
AND SINK BACK INTO IT.
TRUST THE HARNESS.
BRING UP THAT KNEE
A LITTLE BIT MORE.
TATIANA STRUGGLED
A LITTLE.
YOU'VE GOTTA
TRUST THE HARNESS.
YOU'RE A LONG
WAY OFF, HONEY.
SO I'M LIKE
THE LONGEST ONE, HUH?
WELL, YEAH.
HE'S JUST
STRAIGHT TO THE POINT.
THEY WERE TAKING LONG
TO GET TO ME AND I WAS
GETTING, LIKE, IMPATIENT.
YOURS IS ABOUT FLYING.
CHIN'S A LITTLE HIGH.
REBECCA IS
VERY COMFORTABLE ON THE WIRE.
I JUST WISH REBECCA
WOULD GIVE ME
A LITTLE MORE EXPRESSION.
THIS IS LOOKING
A LITTLE AWKWARD RIGHT NOW.
GO UP AND JUST,
KIND OF JUST GO-- AND POUR IT.
THINK OF IT AS YOUR INFANT
AND YOU'RE JUST CRADLING--
THERE YOU GO, SWEETIE.
THIS ONE'S GOOD.
- GREAT JOB.
- THAT WAS ACTUALLY
MICHELLE'S BEST SHOOT.
THAT WAS FUN.
I'M LIKING THAT.
NOW REALLY DIVE
WITH THOSE ARMS, SWEETIE.
DIVE WITH THOSE ARMS LIKE
YOU'RE DIVING INTO THE WATER.
LLUVY, TAKE YOUR HANDS
TO THE OTHER SIDE FOR ME.
I'M A TANGLED FISH.
LLUVY STRUGGLED A LOT
IN THE HARNESS TODAY,
A LITTLE INSECURE
ABOUT HER WHOLE OVERALL POSE.
AND YOU CAN
TRY DIFFERENT THINGS,
BUT AS LONG AS YOU KEEP
THAT KIND OF FISHY MOTION
WITH THE HANDS TOGETHER...
SHE HAD A REALLY HARD TIME
REALLY GRASPING
THE SHAPE THAT WE WANTED.
THANK YOU, GUYS.
THE ONLY THING, LIKE,
I DISAGREE WITH RIGHT NOW
IS THE FACT THAT
BRANDY THREATENED TATIANA.
EVERYBODY'S TALKING
ABOUT SOMETHING THAT
HAPPENED THE OTHER DAY.
AND IF WE COULD HIT PEOPLE,
YOUR ASS WOULD BE
TORE UP RIGHT NOW.
TATIANA DO GOT
A SLICK MOUTH.
I'M SAYING IT
RIGHT HERE IN FRONT OF YOU.
YEAH, YOU DO, OKAY?
SO TWO PEOPLE WITH
TWO SLICK MOUTHS ARE GONNA GET
INTO TROUBLE
WITH EACH OTHER.
BUT I DIDN'T THREATEN HER.
PERSONALLY, I HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT BRANDY HAS AGAINST ME,
BUT BRANDY'S NOT SOMEBODY
I WANNA GET ALONG WITH
OR EVEN TRY
TO BE HER FRIEND.
IF SHE DIDN'T
SAY SOMETHING TO ME,
I WOULDN'T HAVE TO
STAND UP FOR MYSELF.
WELL, I DON'T KNOW, I'M NOT
BRANDY, BUT, LIKE I SAID,
SHE'S NOT GONNA JUST SIT THERE
AND LET NOBODY TALK ABOUT HER.
BRANDY IS SWEET 90% OF THE TIME,
BUT WHEN YOU HAVE
BITCHY GIRLS LIKE TATIANA
THROWIN' FIRE AT BRANDY,
OF COURSE SHE'S GONNA
GET AN ATTITUDE.
BRANDY'S NOT NO LITTLE GIRL.
SHE'S GONNA
STAND UP FOR HERSELF.
I KNOW
IT'S THE END OF THE DAY.
I DON'T NEED TIRED.
- OKAY.
- ALL RIGHT?
CAN YOU LEAN
INTO THE HARNESS?
BECAUSE, RIGHT NOW,
WHAT YOU'RE DOING--
YOU COULD BE STANDING UP THERE
WITHOUT A HARNESS.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
I NEED IT TO LOOK MORE SURREAL.
THINK OF DANCE.
OOH, WAIT A MINUTE.
I'M ABOUT TO FALL.
NO, YOU'RE NOT.
YOU'RE NOT GOIN' ANYWHERE.
I JUST WISH BRANDY WOULD
TAKE COMMAND OF THAT HARNESS
AND JUST, KIND OF, LASH OUT,
KIND OF LIKE A SCORPION WOULD.
YOU GOT IT, BABY.
AFTER
YESTERDAY'S CONFRONTATION,
I KNOW IT'S GONNA BE
A LOT OF HATIN' BEHIND MY BACK,
BUT I'M JUST GONNA
PUT IT LIKE THIS--
I'M HERE,
AND SO NOW LET THE GAMES BEGIN.
I WAS-- OKAY--
IT'S OKAY.
YOU APOLOGIZED
TO ME YESTERDAY,
AND I APOLOGIZED TO YOU.
YEAH, THEN YOU GO OFF AGAIN.
NO, AND THEN YOU KEEP ON
BUMPIN' BEHIND MY BACK.
YOU THREATENED ME.
DON'T GET IN MY FACE.
I'M PULLING BRANDY BECAUSE
BRANDY'S IN TATIANA'S FACE
LIKE SHE'S GONNA HIT HER.
I DON'T WANT BRANDY TO GET
KICKED OUT OF THE COMPETITION
FOR A FIGHT.
IT SEEMS REALLY PETTY
TO BE ARGUING OVER SOMETHING
LIKE--LIKE THIS.
IT'S NOT EVEN ABOUT THAT.
IT'S ABOUT EVERY DAY,
EVERY DAY A GROUP OF GIRLS
COME AT BRANDY
WITH SOMETHING.
EVERYBODY WANNA
GANG UP ON BRANDY.
BRANDY--SHE DOES SOMETHING.
YEAH, MOST OF THE TIME,
SHE'S WRONG.
SO WHAT?
BUT I DO PROTECT HER BECAUSE
THAT'S MY LITTLE SISTER NOW.
I HAVEN'T BEEN
TO ANGER MANAGEMENT,
BUT I'M NOT GONNA LET NOBODY
JUST KEEP COMIN' AT ME
WITH ANGRINESS.
THAT'S WHY SHE'S ALWAYS ANGRY,
'CAUSE EVERYBODY
KEEPS COMING ON HER
WITH NEGATIVITY.
SHE SAYS STAY OUT OF HER FACE,
STAY OUT OF HER FACE.
BRANDY BRINGS OUT
THE OLD TIFFANY,
ME GIVIN' ATTITUDE
TO THE OTHER GIRLS
BECAUSE OF SOMETHING
SHE DID.
ALL Y'ALL BITCHES EVIL.
YOU KNOW SHE'S ANGRY,
WHY PROVOKE HER?
WHY SAY SOMETHING TO HER
THAT'S GONNA PROVOKE HER
TO WANNA SLAP YOU?
- JUST LEAVE HER ALONE.
- I AGREE.
PEOPLE ASKED ME WHAT HAPPENED
AND I VOICED MY STORY
JUST LIKE ANYBODY WOULD DO.
WELL, GREAT, IT'S OVER.
WE CAN GO HOME NOW.
YEAH, IT'S FINE.
IT DON'T
MAKE NO SENSE OF FUSSIN',
IT DON'T MAKE NO SENSE
TO GET NO ATTITUDE.
I'M SAYING THAT IF YOU'VE
GOT SOMETHING TO SAY TO THEM,
SAY IT,
BUT DON'T GO IN NOBODY'S FACE.
DON'T THREATEN THEM.
TIFFANY USED TO BE
VERY ANGRY AND VERY VIOLENT,
AND NOW I SEE HER A LOT OF TIMES
AS BEING VERY PROTECTIVE
AND VERY MOTHERLY.
TYRA MAIL!
"TOMORROW YOU WILL
MEET WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY 11 OF YOU
WILL CONTINUE ..."
"...ON THE ROAD OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
ONE WILL BE ELIMINATED?
YES.
IT'S TO THAT POINT
WHERE EVERYBODY'S SHOWING
THEIR TRUE COLORS.
IT'S ABOUT TO BE
ONLY 11 PEOPLE REMAINING,
AND YOU CAN'T FAKE
FOR TOO LONG.
I HAVE A NEW STRATEGY.
I'M BEING TIFFANY.
THEY COULD EITHER LOVE IT
OR HATE ME FOR IT.
NOW IT'S TIME
TO MAKE OUR THIRD CUT
WHICH WILL BRING US
ONE STEP CLOSER TOWARDS
DETERMINING WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
NOW, YOU ALL KNOW WE HAVE
SOME AMAZING PRIZES, RIGHT?
THE FIRST IS A CONTRACT
WITH THE TOP INTERNATIONAL
MODELING MANAGEMENT COMPANY
FORD MODELS,
A SPREAD IN ELLE MAGAZINE
WHICH WILL BE SHOT
BY WORLD RENOWNED PHOTOGRAPHER
GILLES BENSIMON,
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVER GIRL COSMETICS.
AND OF COURSE WE HAVE
OUR CRAZY JUDGES--
MISS JANICE DICKINSON,
ONE OF THE WORLD'S
FIRST SUPERMODELS,
NIGEL BARKER,
A NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER,
NOLE MARIN,
A PROMINENT FASHION EDITOR
AND STYLIST,
AND OUR SPECIAL GUEST JUDGE
MISS BEVERLY JOHNSON.
BEVERLY IS TOTALLY
ONE OF MY IDOLS.
THIS IS ONE OF THE WOMEN
THAT MADE ME WANT TO MODEL.
AW.
SO, NOW IT'S TIME
FOR YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS.
I GOT A LITTLE FEEDBACK
THAT YOU GUYS HAD A SHOOT
WITH A PHOTOGRAPHER
FROM HELL.
BUT WHAT
YOU GUYS DIDN'T KNOW
WAS THAT THAT SHOOT WAS YOUR
ACTUAL TEST FOR JUDGING TODAY,
AND, MICHELLE,
YOU'RE FIRST.
LET'S SEE IT.
- OOH.
- OH, MY GOSH.
NO MATTER WHAT HAPPENS,
YOU ARE TO ALWAYS REMEMBER
YOU'RE MODELING.
YOU ALSO HAD A SHOOT
IN THE HEAVENS.
HERE IS MICHELLE'S
BEST SHOT.
- WHOA.
- OOH, GORGEOUS.
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY
SPARKADELICIOUS.
OUT OF THIS WORLD.
OKAY, UP NEXT,
WE HAVE NAIMA.
THE GREAT THING ABOUT THIS
IS THERE'S JUNK HAPPENING,
BUT YOU'RE STILL
AWARE OF THE PHOTOGRAPHER.
SO, NAIMA,
YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT.
GOING THROUGH YOUR FILM, THIS IS
ACTUALLY YOUR BEST BODY POSE,
AND I WAS A LITTLE
DISAPPOINTED BECAUSE
YOU'RE THE BALLERINA GIRL.
I DON'T REALLY KNOW
WHAT YOU WERE SAYING
WITH THAT EXPRESSION.
ALL RIGHT, TATIANA,
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WITH THE PHOTOGRAPHER
FROM HELL.
THAT'S A LITTLE
OVER-THE-TOP.
THAT ONE, TO ME, IS LIKE,
"I'M GONNA KICK YOUR ASS."
I QUITE LIKE THAT.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
- THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
- YEAH.
GREAT BODY, BABY.
DOUBLE TROUBLE.
NEXT WE HAVE BRITTANY.
FIRST OFF,
I JUST WANT TO TELL YOU
YOU LOOK SO BEAUTIFUL.
THANK YOU.
YOU NEED TO BECOME
A LITTLE BIT MORE
ELEGANT AND GRACEFUL
IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA
AND OFF THE CAMERA.
AND HERE
IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
THIS WOULD HAVE BEEN
AN EASY SHOOT
TO HAVE GONE PLAYBOY.
I DON'T SEE PLAYBOY
THIS WEEK.
- I SEE A MODEL.
- ABSOLUTELY.
ALL RIGHTY, UP NEXT,
WE HAVE BRANDY.
- HI, BRANDY.
BRANDY, YOU SEEM SAD.
OH, NO, I'M NOT SAD.
I JUST BE CONCENTRATIN',
LIKE, ON THE PICTURES.
DURING THE AUDITIONS
YOU CAME IN THERE.
YOU WERE SO BUBBLY.
YOU WERE SO BRIGHT AND HAPPY
AND IT'S THIS GREAT PERSONALITY
AND IT'S WHAT GOT YOU HERE,
AND WHAT'S GONNA SEND YOU HOME
IS THE NEGATIVE ATTITUDE,
'CAUSE YOU TAKE
BEAUTIFUL PICTURES.
YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT.
- IT'S NOT TERRIBLE.
- MM-HMM, NOT BAD.
THE CAMERA
REALLY LOVES YOU.
AND YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
IN THE HEAVENS.
WOW.
AND, YOU KNOW, BRANDY,
IT SEEMS FROM THESE PHOTOS
YOU CAN BE A MODEL,
BUT, HONEY, YOU NEED
TO JUST CHANGE
THAT ATTITUDE.
OKAY.
KEENYAH.
YOU LOOK BEAUTIFUL,
WHAT A GREAT PROFILE YOU HAVE.
YOU'RE A GORGEOUS GIRL
AND THESE SHOULD NEVER
BE SEEN BY ANYONE, EVER.
- (laughs)
- UNFORTUNATELY,
THAT'S NOT POSSIBLE
RIGHT NOW.
- SO HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
- CELESTIAL.
I THINK THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
UP NEXT, WE HAVE KAHLEN.
SO, KAHLEN,
THE PHOTOGRAPHER SAID
THAT YOU WERE
A VERY PRETTY GIRL,
BUT THE ONE THING
IS THAT HE NOTICED
YOUR LACK OF CONFIDENCE
RIGHT OFF THE BAT.
I WAS JUST REALLY
UPSET ABOUT THE SHOOT,
SO SOME OF THE COMMENTS
REALLY HIT HARD ON MY HEART.
OH, HONEY, GET USED TO IT.
YOU ALSO HAD
A SHOOT IN THE HEAVENS,
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
- WOW, A GORGEOUS FACE.
- IT'S GORGEOUS.
IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
I LIKE THIS BECAUSE YOU'RE
THE TIMID GIRL, AND YOU
LOOK LIKE YOU'RE ABOUT
TO RAM SOMEBODY IN THE WALL.
CHRISTINA.
WELL, YOUR MOUTH IS
EXTRAORDINARILY CRAMPED,
AS USUAL.
ALL THREE OF THOSE SHOTS,
YOU'RE DOING THIS.
YEAH.
PREPARING FOR
A BOTOX INJECTION
JUST DOESN'T CUT IT.
IS THAT
WHAT THEY DO, JANICE?
IS THAT WHAT THEY DO,
JANICE?
OH, YEAH, ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
LOOK.
I HAD IT DONE
ALL LAST WEEK.
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
I THINK THE FEET ARE GOOD,
YOUR BODY LOOKS GREAT.
YOU KNOW,
YOU'RE ALWAYS THE ONE
THAT'S STARING, LIKE, "BITCH,"
YOU KNOW, BUT THIS ONE IS,
LIKE, SO SOFT, SO PRETTY.
HI, NOELLE.
LOSE THAT THING,
THAT POODLE THAT YOU HAD
- RESTING ON TOP OF YOUR HEAD.
- YES.
THAT LOOKS SO MUCH BETTER.
THAT'S SO MUCH BETTER,
THAT'S GORGEOUS.
THESE ARE
DISASTROUS PICTURES.
I THINK THAT YOU'RE NOT
TAKING IT SERIOUSLY ENOUGH.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
YOU JUST DON'T LIFT A LEG.
MY DOG CAN DO THAT.
TO ME, YOU JUST DON'T LOOK
LIKE YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
THANKS, NOELLE.
TIFFANY, SO HOW WAS THE SHOOT
WITH THE PHOTOGRAPHER FROM HELL?
IT WAS A TEST TO SEE
HOW FAR, YOU KNOW, ALONG
I'M COMING
WITH MY ATTITUDE.
DID YOU AT ONE POINT
REALLY WANNA GO OVER THERE
AND JUST LET HIM HAVE IT
WITH THE RACKET?
- HONESTLY, NO. I-I--
- LIAR!
NO, I'M NOT, HONESTLY,
BECAUSE SIX MONTHS AGO,
I PROBABLY WOULD HAVE WANTED
TO BANG HIS HEAD IN.
- OH, ALL RIGHT.
- BUT NOT ANYMORE.
OUCH, OUCH-OOEY.
YOU KNOW,
I LOVE THE HAND MOVING.
AT LEAST WE HAVE
SOME MOVEMENT HERE.
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
I THINK YOU DID NAIL IT.
I LIKE YOUR FACE,
I THINK IT'S VERY MYSTERIOUS.
I THINK IT'S VERY
"DON'T SCREW WITH ME
OR ELSE I'M GONNA CLOBBER YOU
WITH MY CLAWS."
IT'S A GREAT PHOTOGRAPH.
LLUVY.
THERE WAS A VERY FEW
FACIAL EXPRESSIONS BEING GIVEN.
WE KNOW YOU DEFINITELY
HAVE LOTS OF EXPRESSIONS
'CAUSE, JUST STANDING
IN FRONT OF US,
YOU ARE CONSTANTLY CHANGING
AND MOVING AND FIDGETING.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
WELL, YOU LOOK LIKE
A DEAD FISH HERE,
BUT I HAVE TO SEE A CLOSE-UP,
AND YOU LOOK LIKE A DEAD FISH
IN THE CLOSE-UP, TOO.
THE FISH NET AND EVERYTHING--
I FELT BLAH.
THIS IS WHAT
YOU HAVE TO TAKE ON AND WEAR
WHEN YOU BECOME A MODEL,
AND YOU--YOU FAILED MISERABLY.
REBECCA.
SHE'S BACK AND STRONG.
- YAY, REBECCA.
- GOOD.
- WELL, LET'S SEE HOW YOU DID.
- OOH.
LOOKS LIKE
A TOILET BOWL ASS.
NOW WE'RE GONNA
LOOK AT YOUR PHOTO
IN THE HEAVENS.
IT'S A PEDESTRIAN
PHOTOGRAPH.
IT JUST DOESN'T
REGISTER MODEL.
EVEN THOUGH
YOU'RE THE VIRGIN,
YOU'RE THE VIRGIN
THAT EVERYBODY WANTS.
THAT'S RIGHT.
SO YOU HAVE TO BE
VERY SENSUAL.
TYRA, WHEN YOU ARE
STRUTTING DOWN THE RUNWAY
DOING VICTORIA'S SECRET,
WEARING THOSE BAT WINGS,
WHAT ARE YOU THINKIN'?
I AIN'T THINKIN'
I'M NO VIRGIN.
(laughter)
TATIANA.
SHE'S OBVIOUSLY NEW,
BUT I THINK SHE HAS
A LOT OF POTENTIAL.
MICHELLE.
SHE LOOKS LIKE JAY LENO.
AND IF JAY LENO
LOOKED LIKE THIS,
I'D BE INTERESTED
IN JAY LENO.
- KEENYAH.
- THIS FACE IS TO DIE FOR.
IT'S HARD FOR REBECCA
TO TAKE A BAD PICTURE,
BUT IT'S NOT,
LIKE, GREAT.
- LLUVY.
- IT JUST LOOKS HORRENDOUS.
SHE NEEDS
TO BE TUNA TARTAR.
I'M OVER HER.
YOU MEAN YOU COULD HAVE
SERVED IT BETTER WITH
A POUND OF SEQUINS
ON YOUR FACE.
DARLING, I HAVE.
THIS PHOTO
IS ONE OF THE WORST PHOTOS
IN THE HISTORY OF
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
SHE LOOKS
TOTALLY WASHED UP.
- BRITTANY.
- I LOVE BRITTANY.
ONE OF THINGS I THINK
WE'RE LOOKING FOR IS TO SEE
THE PROGRESSION IN SOMEBODY,
AND SHE HAS LEARNED.
BRANDY.
SHE HAS AN EXTREMELY
STRONG AND EXOTIC FACE.
BUT BRANDY'S LIKE,
SORT OF LIKE DEATH WARMED UP.
I MEAN,
SHE JUST DOESN'T SMILE.
SHE IS SO ANGRY,
BUT SHE'S SO DAMN BEAUTIFUL
IN THE FACE.
- NAIMA.
- NAIMA?
NOW PRANCER, NOW DANCER
NOW DONNER, NOW BLITZEN.
IS SHE REALLY A BALLERINA?
I WOULD DO A LIE DETECTOR
TEST ON THAT ONE.
NOELLE.
IF NOELLE COULD
MAKE A TRANSFORMATION,
SHE COULD BE HOT.
THIS GIRL DOES NOT
KNOW HOW TO MODEL AT ALL.
KAHLEN.
I THINK SHE
IS AN INSECURE GIRL
THAT HAS HIGH SELF-ESTEEM
IN THE MAKING.
YES.
- TIFFANY.
- SHE'S REALLY A STRIKING GIRL.
TO WORK THOSE BIG RED CLAWS
WAS HARD AND I THINK SHE DID IT.
SHE IS MODEL POTENTIAL.
CHRISTINA.
FOR ME, THIS IS
ONE OF THE BEST PICTURES
OF THE BUNCH.
BUT I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT,
IN TODAY'S LOOK,
TO HAVE A MOUTH.
WORK THAT MOUTH.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE IT
BY BIRTH, GET IT.
THERE ARE 12 OF YOU
THAT STAND BEFORE ME,
AND THERE ARE ONLY
11 PHOTOS IN MY HANDS,
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE YOUNG LADIES THAT WILL
CONTINUE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME THAT
I'M GOING TO CALL--
BRITTANY.
BRITTANY, YOU WENT FROM TRIPLE-X
PORN STAR QUEEN
LAST WEEK
TO QUEEN OF THE GALAXY.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL--
KEENYAH.
MICHELLE.
KAHLEN.
YOUR CONFIDENCE IS--
IT'S GETTING THERE.
IT'S NOT ALL THE WAY THERE,
BUT I DO SEE PROGRESS.
THANK YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
CHRISTINA.
REBECCA.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU, TYRA.
TATIANA.
NAIMA.
TIFFANY.
TIFFANY, THIS PHOTO
IS ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL.
IT SHOWS JUST HOW FAR
YOU'VE COME.
NOELLE.
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR YOU
TO LISTEN,
OR YOU'RE JUST GONNA LEAVE
THE SAME GIRL THAT
YOU CAME HERE AS.
THIS IS
ABOUT TRANSFORMATION.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
WILL LLUVY AND BRANDY
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS.
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT WILL STILL BE
IN THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I WILL ONLY
CALL ONE NAME.
THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO YOUR LOFT,
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS,
AND LEAVE.
ONE OF YOU HAS AN ATTITUDE
WITH A CAPITAL "A."
THE JUDGES AREN'T SURE
IF IT'S SOMETHING
THAT CAN BE
HEALED IN 12 WEEKS.
AND ONE OF YOU HAS ONLY
TAKEN ONE GOOD PHOTO.
TONIGHT,
ABOUT YOUR PISCES PICTURE,
I EVEN SAID
THAT IT'S THE WORST PHOTO
IN THE HISTORY
OF "AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL."
THE JUDGES FEEL LIKE
ONE OF YOU
HAS A LITTLE
BIT MORE POTENTIAL
THAN THE OTHER.
CONGRATULATIONS, LLUVY.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
- THANKS.
- YOU'RE WELCOME.
THANK YOU, BRANDY.
I DON'T REGRET
DOING ANYTHING ELSE DIFFERENTLY.
IF THEY WOULD HAVE TOOK OUT
THE TIME TO LOOK PAST
WHAT THEY THOUGHT WAS ATTITUDE,
THEN MAYBE THEY WOULDA SAW
THE REAL ME,
BUT WHATEVER.
I'LL MISS TIFFANY.
NEVER HAD A BIG SISTER,
I ALWAYS WANTED ONE.
SHE BECAME ONE
FOR THE SHORT TIME I WAS HERE
AND I'LL MISS HER
FOR THAT.
STAY TUNED FOR SCENES
FROM OUR NEXT EPISODE.
COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
THESE LITTLE THINGS
ON MY FACE, AND--
- LET ME SEE.
- SEE?
THE COMPETITION
TAKES A BACK SEAT
WHEN DISEASE BRINGS DANGER
TO THE HOUSE.
THERE'S THESE NEW
FLESH-EATING BACTERIA THINGS
AND PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
DYING FROM IT.
WHAT?
OOH, I'M ITCHING.
WILL MICHELLE'S FACE BE
FIERCE OR FATAL?
WE'RE ALL GONNA DIE!